what's up you cuny [ __ ] welcome
to another episode of get close
where i your co-host gio tries to
[ __ ] not choke out bart
every episode now why
i don't know you just get on my goddamn
nerves these days really
uh no i'm just kidding oh no no yeah for
real i do i get on your nerves these
days yeah it's probably because you're
on your period not on these days uh just
when we film because it's exactly the
last five days we'll start all over
we don't have to be on the nose about it
no
no i was feeling it are you aware start
all over it's fine okay okay uh now it's
just the real one right here
ready yep three two one welcome to
another episode of get close i'm your
co-host gio i'm bart
hi bart hi
you know i was like reading some of the
comments
and uh i think people really like how
uh real
and like vulnerable that we are on
camera
because like we just
talk [ __ ] to each other like no one else
what the [ __ ] cut it you're talking
about [ __ ] about on the nose and
you're literally on the nose
no i'm talking about the comments
i'm not saying i'm not funny i'm not
acting it i'm telling it that's
different
okay you're acting the part i'm telling
you i thought it was show don't tell
that's the best
it's so cool okay start all over because
you cut me up for being on the nose and
you're literally on the nose [ __ ] it
let's start all over and let's go give
me a big [ __ ] kiss
a good one
i can't breathe get away
what the [ __ ] is going on
okay
what's the [ __ ] improv game we used
to play
it doesn't [ __ ] matter you're a [ __ ]
let's go
[ __ ] batch botch
let's go what was it zips absolutely a
bunch of them oh
okay good
are you good do you feel your anxiety
nope 8 19. okay ready yep three two one
what's up everybody welcome to an
episode of get close i'm your co-host
geo and i'm bart
and bart what um so uh i forgot what we
were talking about
but you brought up and this totally
surprised me because we've been together
for 15 years
um
and or like about to be yeah 13 13. no
about to be fourteen yeah
one of those things it's about fifteen
years it feels like it's about 15 yeah
it feels like it's been way too goddamn
long like we need a divorce soon yep um
but so at this point i feel like i know
everything about you i feel like i can't
[ __ ] you're gonna let me finish yes
cool thank you i feel like i can write
your [ __ ] biography like i feel like
i can make your life decisions you're in
a coma i know everything that you want
to do that's what i feel like you don't
know what i have underneath the drawers
what drawers and why are they underneath
and not in because that's how you hide
[ __ ] underneath your door
anyway
uh when you when you have drawers oh
underneath the bottom yeah you pull it
out you put underneath right there well
i don't need to be dumb
when you go like this no one knows
what's in there yeah why are you trying
to hide that you know that was one of my
uh porn hiding spots no one of my worst
nightmares
so you know how i used to sell sex toys
okay okay okay yes so i sell sex toys
right so i had a pocket [ __ ] or a
fleshlight and then so i was uh wait so
you would sell it and also use it of
course i gotta write a good good copy
for it okay wait so how did that happen
were you like like uh counting inventory
and it says like 50 should have been
shipped and you're like there's only 49.
or you just told yourself this is my
friend's company so you told your friend
hey i'm going to take one for myself
yeah
and then he was like oh that's cool so
my friend looking weird my friend uh so
i got into his business because we were
selling textbooks at first he's just a
businessman so anything can find a good
margin he's gonna sell so he found these
international versions of textbooks and
i think a regular textbook would go for
like 80 bucks to like over a hundred
yeah that was so surprising when i went
to [ __ ] school yeah i didn't think
like books were that expensive i'm like
what why is this [ __ ] book 130 and
then you get the exact same textbook
yeah meant for like india or something
right and then that exact same textbook
with the same content it's different
just formatted differently
it's now
40 bucks
but it's just pictures are a little bit
smaller like just little like really
like are you saying india and indian
eyes are different than us eyes no i'm
saying that there's a scam going on
because the it has to do with the
publishing what my friend was explaining
to me so you know on books that like the
isbn number yep i don't know if it's the
same or whatever that i don't even
remember that i sold textbooks
so did i but i don't remember any of
that [ __ ] yeah so like the same exact
book just formatted differently like one
might be on eight and a eight and a half
by eleven the other one's like a
different format yeah all of a sudden
they could change it so he was able to
sell it for 40 bucks because he got it
for five bucks
imagine getting a legit hardcover
textbook for five bucks that i sold for
40. and then so once um i think the
american schools or colleges or maybe
the only yeah there's only like a window
of time where that shit's popping and
flying off the shelves and then the
semester starts so they don't need it's
just not that hot yeah um but whatever
their like rights company or whatever
caught on to that they banned it so he
wasn't able to import those anymore
but because he was so heavy on ebay he
wanted to continue that so he started he
found out his dad um his dad's like a
politician in china and
in his like area they have a lot of
plastics manufacturing so he was able to
get like all these catalogs of all these
like plastic products in the same
catalog you'll find kids tricycles
pocket [ __ ] drum sets like because in
china they're just a workforce right so
they don't give a [ __ ] what they're
producing yeah it's just like produce i
just want to produce i just want to make
money feed my found that's all they care
about so they don't even know what it is
they just see [ __ ] plastic titties
coming through they don't even care so
uh it's actually pretty tight
that mindset yeah cause that they're not
passing judgment they're just like i
gotta work i gotta work yeah i gotta
secure the bag yeah there's a demand for
these i don't care i'm just working [ __ ]
it i don't care so um i started helping
himself sell those and since his english
wasn't like his best strength um i
started writing like descriptions for
him for all these like sex toys and i'd
go to his house and we'd meet and then
he would have just sex toys like from
like floor to ceiling and he was living
with his mom was it like in a package or
was it out of packages
um he kept inventory like in the
packages but then he'll have him all out
too because he has to take photo pic
like product picks you know that's
amazing yeah his mom his mom
[ __ ] black ass dick there's like a
swiss ball
with a [ __ ] dick on it so you're
supposed to straddle it and bounce up
and down on it oh
you know those like you know can you
imagine like those balls it's not a
[ __ ] hard thing to imagine i got it
yeah and his mom would be like isn't my
son crazy and i'm like no i think her
son's actually like a genius uh crazy
because she could only she can't she
couldn't see past the sex toys yeah
because just living room full of [ __ ]
dildos and [ __ ] rings and stuff
like this that's that big
no no not just [ __ ] rings but like the
whole set like the theme that goes to
the pitches the nipple the whole thing
yeah the whole like uh s m like leather
strap up all that stuff so he had like
everything in his room so he can take
touch it take pictures of it i'm writing
the copy of it and then he had another
roommate wait how did you get in contact
with this guy it seems like it's such a
random relationship yeah
oh you know what i met him at bally's
all right the gym okay
so um i used to train at bally's and
this is like old-school bodybuilder days
where like i would have like cut off t's
like um like training old school like
ronnie coleman style
and i think
i was one of the few people in the
morning that would like train my ass off
and this guy is like a guy straight from
china and i don't know how he knows but
he was super into the bodybuilding scene
so he knew all the people like marcus
rule branch warren ronnie coleman jay
cutler like all the all those guys and
he was seeing me training like that
style like going ham [ __ ] sweat
dripping all over the place and he goes
oh man you train really hard can i start
training with you i'm like yeah of
course i'm like i don't know what the
hell i'm doing i'm just reading these
magazines and going ham he goes no i
want to do it too i love like
bodybuilding so we would like train hard
and we'll do like pose downs in the
mirror and then that thing was pretty
jacked too or
jacked
he got that northern chinese
bone structure
what the [ __ ] does that mean
so like
he um
he wasn't jacked because he didn't
really train for that long
but his natural stature is like
5 11 220.
okay gotcha like he just got that
northern like you just okay this guy's
like [ __ ] what northern chinese are
known to just be like stockier and
taller yeah again like
me i see like my mom's northern chinese
friends it's pretty normal for them to
be like six one or six two oh [ __ ] yeah
so like the the ones that that came here
they're like the railroad workers i
don't think they could pack that many on
the ships so they probably told all the
northern chinese guys you guys gotta
stay back because for every one of you
guys you could pack like three of these
so the northern chinese guys they stayed
there and then they're just big mofos
got it so that's how you bet about
bellies sweaty with your little [ __ ]
little tiny nipples sticking out yes
digging out the sides and then i think
we got to talking and then he'll be like
hey would you be interested in this
would you be interested is that and then
uh the first thing was like hey um for
some for
i think winter break he goes i really
need help selling these textbooks
okay good
what would you have said if he's like
sex toys
you're like i'm down i didn't care i was
in i was like in such a hustle mode
because i really wanted to put rims on
my truck that i'll do anything
so like at that time i was like how much
are you how much uh would you pay me and
he goes um
i think it was like four grand for two
weeks what the [ __ ] i'm in yeah exactly
he's like but i need you on call though
he's like ebay is a 24-hour business i
was like i don't give a [ __ ]
the crazy two weeks that's the [ __ ] the
crazy thing is
that
uh
that winter break i believe
was the exact break that i also got at
in the marine corps at is annual
training so that was my two weeks that i
had to go train
fortunately this time it wasn't in the
field
so that was i think one of my first
tastes of like hustle because the marine
corps schedule is like 4 00 a.m to at
least like 5 p.m
so
i would uh for two weeks i would go 4
a.m
go down to long beach where my unit was
we'd i would work until like 5 p.m
and then he knew that i had that but he
still wanted my help because i think
just through a conversation he felt like
i was smart or something
oh yeah
i don't know what he was listening to
really i thought you said i was smart
no
okay well you're lost and then so i
would uh meet up with him and then from
7 00 p.m till 2 a.m i would work for him
and then you'd go back to work
yeah at that time on my four g's for two
weeks i don't give a [ __ ] i'll die you
know i'll just have her
i'll do it when you're in college yeah
yeah 500 bucks is a 500 bucks that lasts
your home especially back in the day
when you went to college that that used
to be more than something like y'all's
like holy [ __ ] four g's i'm like dude my
i think the the rims and suspension i
wanted was like three grand so that
covered it
and then so like yeah i would do that
and then i uh i had a fever because you
know you know how my body works like if
i don't sleep for like three or four
days i get sick real easy i had a fever
i still went to both i was i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm gonna make this money and
then uh rims
oh my gosh and then there's this and we
met this whole underground textbook
circuit which is pretty crazy like we
would meet up with this guy in torrance
um because you know it's like because of
publishing rights whatever these books
that are like
uh made in this country that's probably
why there's a giant markup you
technically can't ship it to somewhere
else
you know like so if you have like uh
this chemistry book it's printed in the
us it's made to be sold in the us so
that's supposed to be like 100 bucks
the one in pakistan or even though or
india even though it's the same exact
contents or whatever but it's using like
indian labor that's probably why it's so
cheap but then they ship it over here he
gets it for five bucks so we would go
and we meet up in the middle of the
night and we would go to like those um
you know like those business parks where
it's just like every unit looks
identical
so we would go there and then he would
meet up with this dude i mean like the
dude like looking around like that as if
just for [ __ ] books yeah like he's
like selling drugs or something and i'm
like this is our fault are the cops on
the [ __ ]
book lookout like they just that was
there it's like we gotta we gotta get
weeds and meth off the street and
[ __ ] foreign textbooks that's the
dope thing is because you're moving
textbooks it goes right under their nose
i mean it's not like duct taped freaking
bricks of stuff yeah it's like you just
see like four geeky ass asians pushing a
cart of books you just go freaking
geeks you know yeah they look at they
can't stop studying except they're
underground millionaires you know so we
would go and then uh it would be like
you know those identical units where you
can't even tell it's like 101 102 103
like those type of suites right well and
to the naked eye you can't tell like if
you're not in the book industry you're
not going to be able to decipher which
ones from here which one's from there or
whatever they just all look like [ __ ]
american textbooks yeah exactly and then
so he would open the the door is he
still looking over his shirt yeah
looking around this is like 1am
oh look and open the door was it
intentionally done at 1am because like
you need it to be secret i think because
they're geeks they think it's drugs oh i
see but then from my perspective on my
dude this you could totally operate
right in front of like the sheriff's
department right no one gives a [ __ ]
exactly like i don't even know if they
have like who what's the uh
agency that would be in charge of this
because not the atf not dea maybe fbi i
don't even know like is what's
international publishing rights
what is this i don't know but i'd love
to hear them [ __ ] try to be all bad
at the isbn agency i don't even know
but he would open the suite right yeah
when he opens it this is what the part
that blew my mind when we walked in
there was [ __ ] [ __ ] everywhere
just making like dogs naked chicks yeah
what do you mean no there's no naked
chicks yeah cause i'm like they're geeky
as [ __ ] what are you talking about they
don't even [ __ ] love money
yeah but [ __ ] geeky dudes can't
[ __ ] pull that you just pull out your
wad of cash and then chicks are
salivating like crazy
what do you mean chicks why do you make
it sound like it's a [ __ ] general
statement
because it's the truest thing that ever
lived no it's not i'm with you and
you're [ __ ] broken i'm [ __ ]
balling yeah right you saw my bingo
yesterday what bet our bank account yeah
and i didn't see it how much is it there
a lot
no so we opened the door this part that
blew my mind when we opened the door and
i looked in he actually owned all the
units and he knocked all the walls down
and i was like oh [ __ ] because at first
i thought it was oh he got like 101. so
he got completely [ __ ] is what you're
telling me because eventually they
[ __ ] banned all that
i don't know maybe i mean it's like uh
wolf on wall street right like as the
when you skyrocket to the top on
something that's unregulated
the crash comes hard so we open we open
the door but this is me like 19 20 years
old so all this stuff is like mind
blowing to me i've never heard any type
of stuff like this any type of operation
ever been involved in anything like this
this was to me was like like legal
gangsterism you know i mean like because
i used to sell drugs and we used to do
like our own operations and stuff and
but then like you're dressed apart you
know you look kind of thug you act a
certain way you hit people up that's
just like white collar crime exactly and
it's always just mind-blowing we're like
oh [ __ ] you mean like
no one's gonna hit me up
jump me for my weed yeah cops aren't
gonna arrest me maybe other cop i mean
maybe other [ __ ] textbook dealers
might they might yeah but like
like you could put a police dog into
that building that was gonna go why are
you wasting my time and walk right out
like the smell is really indian in here
and that's it
you know so we open the suite and then
it's just imagine like like five units
down yeah all walls emptied and then uh
uh textbooks from floor to ceiling on
shelves
all the way around like this
and then so we would go would bring um
like dollies and stuff
pack his truck or his van and then we
bring it in and then the crazy part is
like
in that world they also know what the
coke and the heroin and the fentanyl is
like they know which book is the most
sought after and what is the highest
price what what was it i forgot what it
was but he would ask us do you have this
book and then that guy he would like
look at him in the eye like
he's all trying to play hardball like
he's like thinking about like if i
should like let you know
it was fine come to my house
so we ended up going to his house and
what was crazy you go in his house you
know those sheds that people have like
the gardening ones yeah yeah yeah we go
on this back what was this motion what
[ __ ] like a lawnmower oh
we go in his backyard
and he has shed next to shed next to
shed of all books
you see why be a baller and then have
your [ __ ] living spaces look like
[ __ ]
i think geek got geek tendencies you
know all right because for me if i'm if
i'm ballin my place is gonna look ballin
you ever been to like a videographer's
house
is this a trick question like they sleep
with their tripods and stuff what do you
mean
they're [ __ ] geeks anyone that ever
holds a camera in their hand they're
[ __ ] geeky
they sleep with the camera strap on
their neck you never seen that
no are you [ __ ] with me yeah
i was like what no but like geeks got
geek tendencies yeah so it's like you go
there and then um maybe they want to
keep their precious belongings closer or
whatever they don't trust i don't think
it's geek tendencies i think it's more
so they're just practical they're like
wait why would i spend that's probably
why they're balling because they know
how to [ __ ] yeah keep their money and
not be [ __ ] uh frivolous like me yeah
so we'd pack his car would go back and
then we were that's how we used to sell
those textbooks
uh okay so then
um
oh and then so back to the pocket [ __ ]
what up guys this episode of get close
is brought to you by manscaped sweaty
sac summer is approaching and it's time
for you to prioritize the comfort of
your crutch that's why the kings of
crotch comfort manscaped have spent two
years designing the most comfortable
boxer briefs out there i've had the
honor of testing these out because i'm
actually wearing them right now and they
are extremely comfortable and it has the
softest fabric of any of the underwear
that i own it's so breathable it's like
the gills of your groin if you think of
your groin as a fish they even trademark
the jewel pouch so you know it's serious
i think it's time you invest in your
family jewels so let your bulge breathe
and get 20 off plus free shipping when
you use the code get close at
manscape.com and i'm so glad that they
came out with these because one of the
most horrible moments for me and my
groin is when i travel like you know
when you're traveling you're you're
running you're walking sometimes you're
about to miss a flight or a flight gets
delayed and then you're on the plane
where your legs are together and so
you're you barely have any breathing
room right there and you gotta catch
another flight and you experience all
kinds of temperatures hot cold hot cold
stuffy and you're in california air and
then you're in like vegas air and then
you're in texas air and then you're in
your own gunk for over 12 hours and for
me
i
hate that because i like to take a
shower but if i don't have a choice if i
don't have that option then i just got
to wear the most comfortable clothes
ever so i'm so happy that they came out
with these boxers because they are
extremely breathable they're soft and it
keeps your man parts way drier than your
typical underwear and you right now you
can get 20 off plus free shipping with
the code get close at manscape.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
the code get close at manscape.com peace
so i would help so once that business
was out the out the um wazoo down the
drain
yeah um
then i'm gonna try to fill in your
sentences with the most random [ __ ] yeah
so once that was uh down the drain he
had a partner
uh not a partner roommate
that wasn't in his business the kiki guy
or my northern chinese my northern
chinese so he had a roommate and he
lived at his mom's house yeah yeah
so that [ __ ] is confusing that
arrangement is dope though the
arrangement is dope because of this so
he first moved from china with his mom
and they shared a place
when he started to ball out he kicked
his mom out no he wanted to get a bigger
place but he wanted to always take care
of his mom
so as he moved even though he wanted to
get a roommate and stuff he still
brought his mom along so that was like
really cool of him so he had another
roommate his other roommates even
another bigger northern chinese dude
this one was like the weakest 6-2 guy
i've ever seen because you start
bringing him around valleys and i'm like
dude for a big [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] weak um i don't even know why i
had to bring that up because it doesn't
add anything it sounds like you're
hating that he's six two and you're only
five nine i really i really that's true
cause i walk around with them i look
small yeah um but yeah i mean you look
small in general do i yeah
you look you look like a small little
pocket [ __ ]
yeah
so yeah uh his roommate which what was
funny is he would test all the products
and so i didn't know funny about that
well because he's not even part of the
team
so he's just so he's not testing it he's
just jacking off
exactly okay so i would go in his room
and then it would be like butt cheeks
you know like that was just half butt
cheeks like just laying on the floor
with the [ __ ] staring at you that that
would be on the floor uh there'd be like
a pocket [ __ ] on the floor there's like
a random vibrator like like a vibing on
the floor yeah just on the floor and
then i was like
i was like oh what is this i'm testing
all the products and i'm oh cool and
then i'm like wait are you his name was
scott are you part scott's team he goes
no i just tried for fun and then i was
like
all right so
me doing all that stuff i was like and
it was just around right next to you
yeah you're just so desensitized and i
was like is it better than jacking off
he goes oh yeah that's way better he
talks in like a northern like oh yeah
she's weighing some better like a like a
northern chinese accent like where's the
better you know they really go yeah you
teach me like the whole thing like you
get like ky jelly or whatever lubricant
you put that in the microwave for a
little bit so it gets warm and then you
you pour it all over the uh the pocket
[ __ ] or the butt cheeks on the floor
and then you would stick your dick in it
and it was like felt really good it was
way better than your hand and i was like
oh [ __ ]
i think i need to try this you're a
[ __ ] geek so you're a geek amongst
kids i got one so i got one and then
that was my worst nightmare because you
know my mom like just busted into my
house oh i was like wait live with your
mom like any time right like she would
always bust into my house so she's
busting while you're busting i know so
the place that i thought would be the
best to hide it
would be like underneath the drawers
um
put it there and then close the drawer
back up
but i was always scared that like let's
say i died or something
and then you know when like when they
come and they have to yeah they have to
clear your house
just take it all just take everything
put that salvation army just put that in
my garage and then they open the drawers
like what the [ __ ] is that oh you had a
[ __ ] pocket [ __ ] that was your worst
nightmare one pocket [ __ ] yeah just one
pocket [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] you're
dead
why do i want i just know how my mom
would feel about it and i just think she
like doesn't know how to okay the fact
that she's not thinking that you're
jacking off nor having sex is [ __ ]
dumb she doesn't i don't think she does
at all that's [ __ ] too naive
she needs a rude awakening yeah i think
she's yeah i think she should i don't
think she does
yeah so that was your biggest nightmare
my mom finding it that's why i used to
hide my pocket [ __ ] i never had toys
when i lived with my mom so i was never
scared of [ __ ] why
why was i never scared of [ __ ] or why i
never had him why you never had toys
um so this is before the internet where
was i supposed to go i was on [ __ ]
house arrest by my parents your sisters
and your older sister never be like hey
this is what i rub my [ __ ] with or
whatever oh no we never talked about any
of that [ __ ] so how'd you jack off
dude the [ __ ] old school way which is
what
um ride the ball what does that mean
like the old school rate right what the
[ __ ] is red the bull like you find a
[ __ ] male cow and you straddle it and
you and you and you where do you think i
live you try to start a fire on the
spine where do you think i lived
i lived in [ __ ] east l.a not a
[ __ ] ranch land with [ __ ] bulls
and cows then i don't know then what do
you do you ride a bicycle in place
stationary bike
um so i was never i i was and i still am
not like a [ __ ] insert [ __ ] in my
[ __ ] type of chick um i've always been
about clitoral stimulation good for you
i don't think you i don't remember how
the first time i discovered it was
but
um i knew that i definitely took
advantage of
the
um
in the bathtub like when the water comes
out
what that part not the shower head but
the other one
the
spigot yeah from there
how do you what do you do you just like
the water comes out and then you just
[ __ ] open your legs and the water is
just stimulating your [ __ ] [ __ ] and
it feels good like that yeah is it
awkward though isn't it like small like
the bathtubs all small it's awkward as
[ __ ] but when you're a horny little
teeny bopper like you're down to do
whatever you gotta orgasm from that yeah
100
how long does it take for the water to
be running i've never been a long draggy
uh
like it doesn't take me long to
to as what you would call bust nuts yeah
um so maybe
five minutes or less she's my mom time
to take a shower yeah pretty much i
wonder if she ever knew probably she's
probably she's just taking so goddamn
she's just [ __ ] water bill here's
your hands on the bathtub
and she could hear your like feet like
pushing the shower curtain and it's like
shh
my daughter takes showers a lot of
movement yeah yeah maybe i don't know i
i don't know if i would ever ask her we
never really had an open conversation
like that
i don't know if i want to have it
i don't know if i'm that open with my
sexuality i like how open your mom is
with me though what do you mean
because remember i had like a little bit
of cough and then your mom was like hey
uh you can get the cough drops oh where
are they i'm like they're next to my
nightstand she goes but just ignore the
vibrator in there
trying to get naughty with me
oh my god no she would never tell me
she's like that
never oh no i didn't grow up with maybe
i'm too much of a prude or maybe i don't
give off that vibe of like um
me wanting to talk about it or hear
about it it makes me kind of
uncomfortable to be honest
what about with uh taika you think
you're gonna be like the open parent
like oh yeah 100
i just think with that relationship with
my family because it was never an open
discussion about that yeah i don't want
to hear my brother's stuff i don't want
to hear my sister's stuff either one of
my sisters
i don't want to hear my mom's stuff i'm
good i'll hear anyone else's [ __ ]
because i think it's funny yeah
not my family you know like meet the
[ __ ] yeah are you you think you'd be
more like the dustin hoffman type uh
family
dustin oh no that's way too nuts like
ben stiller's parents are really open
about it they want to hear about it yeah
no you want to talk about it enjoy it no
i'm good
you don't want to do that so what do you
want to be
um i just want to be open and and you
share what you want to share with me but
i'm not going to pry and i'm not going
to like
try to like open up and be that way with
you you know what i mean yeah like if it
if i feel that i need to do it then i'll
do it
and i'll like
i'll just make it feel comfortable to
talk about that but besides that i'm
like i don't want to know your stuff oh
sexy what about you
i think i want to get as close to taika
as possible
yeah but how do you do that like are you
gonna start opening up about everything
no i'll wait for him yeah same but if um
oh i'm never i'm always gonna like
whatever he tells me instead of meeting
him i'm always gonna like try to push it
like one step higher give me an example
and if he follows it
then so for example like he's like hey
dad like uh there's this girl that i saw
at school like like
my parents got really tired yeah every
time like we we we
hug or whatever like
my pants get really tight you know then
i'll be like oh like uh
if you thought about what you guys
wanted to do are you guys together or
like what's going on you know or like
try to like
try to uh instead of going oh that just
means you know you're aroused so so your
bp gets really hard oh my god
i think i want to be a gossip girl i
want to gossip with him you know i'm
like oh and like like did she like you
though like you know try to go like that
i can't even imagine you being like that
really why yeah i don't know you're just
not like that really yeah you're not a
gossip girl i think that's why you have
sons so you could be gossip girls or
gossip boys you got some boys you got
some boys with your boys
uh not really yeah so then what why do
you think you're gonna do with your son
because um i feel like my relationship
with my son's gonna be way better
than with your own friends
yeah oh cause you know like when you um
cause isn't that just a precursor to
like how you'll be
just in general with relationships i
think if you want it to be that way so
my dad is in a um so my dad is like
more machismo than my generation right
so for him he's like they don't even
talk about sex
she just goes like do you even know how
to do your homework
like that kind of stuff you know that's
not machismo at all so in the chinese
culture maybe he's just maybe he's a
gentleman no the chinese culture that is
like because you dance around it like
and everyone's supposed to be a pro i
don't think you understand what machismo
means what does it mean um like super
masculine like like you have to like put
it out there that you have a big dick
and big balls you know the man does man
[ __ ] like this you know the man that's
much more yeah
oh that's not the definition of my
cheese on chinese that's called machismo
is a [ __ ] spanish word what are you
talking about being a dumbass
i mean you're sure oh okay
so i'm talking about chinese machismo
yeah um that that's that's a gentleman
dude i think chinese machismo probably
is gentlemen um now i gotta look it up
let's go yeah so if uh in chinese
machismo um they don't talk about that
stuff you just know how to do it and
give it to her right
okay and uh then you come to find out
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing because nobody's talking about it
exactly and then yeah you see strong and
aggressive masculine pride
yeah so that's not much easier at all i
think they're just being so
okay um and then in my generation like
we might share a little bit more right
like me and joe in college we might be a
little bit more like gossip girly but
you still there's still that kind of
like i hear that male
that male like gap male avoidance where
you don't really connect hard on certain
things yeah all you say is yeah we
[ __ ] yeah like that's kind of it yeah
but then with my kid i want to be tight
with them you know so like all of the
preconceived ego or machismo or whatever
i want to throw that out the window and
i just want to be his best friend so
however deep he wants to talk about it
i'm down to talk about it to that level
yeah i wonder at what point you have to
start
or maybe it starts from even now like
having super
conversa like super deep conversations
like that
like where
leading up to that topic isn't already
it doesn't make you feel a type of way
like a like a like a heaviness or like a
scared way well the way that i see it is
you have to establish the freeway
and then there's different cars that go
down the freeway and what's the freeway
um
the open line of communication first
so like if you can't talk to like let's
say i'm just gonna use myself as an
example if i can't talk to taika
about bugs right now for 15 minutes we
don't have that freeway we have like
maybe a little alley so when you have
that alley as you grow up when i talk
about other things like sex it's going
to be like an alley
you know
when we have that freeway we talk about
bugs when i talk about why that's his
favorite rock we have a big old freeway
of communication so when as we as it
progresses it that could fit a
motorcycle it could fit a semi truck
full of information it could fit
whatever but it's establishing the
freeway so that's what i think so like
with me with him i try to like
keep that freeway open
as much as possible i just don't think
it's fair fair to who to what i just
don't think it's fair that
we're given this [ __ ] thing
and we're told to raise it and teach it
values and and and help it stay healthy
and guide it and like for [ __ ] years
right yeah and then at one point out of
nowhere then we're supposed to [ __ ]
let go of the [ __ ] steering wheel and
now they take it over i don't think
that's fair
you would rather let go of the steering
wheel away earlier
yes i can i don't [ __ ] get hurt when
i i'm like that's it you don't need me
you think you're gonna be one of those
crying moms at the college you know when
they send them off to like the dorms and
then the you're gonna be on the crying
pants
100 i [ __ ] cried the first day of
school when i dropped them off that's
all true i forgot i [ __ ] cried but so
you you cried because of what because i
cried too but i cried for a different
reason what did you do i cried because i
was like oh was this too early to have
him go to school because it was pre-k
and i'm like oh it's like he's not gonna
be like what if these strangers aren't
good to him yeah i just found out that
one of his classmates is six
yeah [ __ ] that's crazy is that the very
he's the youngest yeah but he's four the
other kid's six he's about to be five so
he so he's right at the cut-off
the second september so the other kid's
gonna turn seven in kindergarten
yeah that one is interesting i'm like
wow yeah maybe he's at the later like at
the [ __ ] tail end of all of it
daffodil's gonna be like 23 when he
graduates high school
mexican math it made sense to me yeah
um but yeah i just don't think it's fair
like what the [ __ ] because i don't like
it when i dropped off the first date
i was cherry-eyed because of you were
what i cheery oh because of how cute he
was
you know he's like to me it's so cute to
see like someone take the next they were
happy tears yeah and it was like see it
was so like
such a [ __ ] mixed reaction yeah so
cuny to see him like take the next step
in life
like he's like turning into a big boy
you know like he has shoes that have
shoe laces that cross
you know it's not it's not a velcro
velcro yeah and he like he has a little
backpack
it's not that little it's like bigger
than his body yeah it's like him like um
he uses that backpack for [ __ ]
nothing by the way
it's been empty this whole year like
it's like first day on the job you know
so it just made me like it just you made
me feel like really cuny you sound like
you're gonna cry right now you [ __ ]
i'm just kidding i know um
no i was crying because i'm just like
you know you control the environment
that you raise your kid in right yeah so
like i know what he's eating i know my
tone that i talk to him i know what it
like i am 100
zoned in on him want nothing but the
best for him
he'll annoy me but like it's it he's
supposed to he's my son yeah right so
even the annoyance that i i do feel
with him it's it's still uh it has so
much love behind it whereas a complete
stranger has zero ties to him so if they
get annoyed they're [ __ ] annoyed
um so i'm like they're gonna treat him
completely different so i was just
thinking the most negative [ __ ]
scenarios ever and i'm like
they're gonna [ __ ] be so mean to him
and like
you know so i was just thinking worst
case scenarios completely heartbroken
so now i think of like the next phase in
his life you don't have faith in the
school
i don't have faith in people
all people are [ __ ] animals
not all people okay
we are we are all animals it's very rare
to have someone that's very [ __ ]
dialed in you don't think there's a uh
a filtering process for certain things
like there is but people i mean people
think you think you'll find a lazy
person in the nba
no
see not everyone is everyone
yeah but now you're talking about
something where there's like ultra
filtration and you think his school is
something like that like it's the nba
version i i uh so the way that i look at
things
everything in the world is a waiting or
filtering out pros process right
so because of that things get charged a
premium i don't know so like okay go
continue
like uh what's up what's a really good
example okay
you know i i like uh firearms right
one of the companies that one of my
favorite
uh
these guys are extremely expensive you
know why
because for every like i think like
three or four made
they throw out three of them
oh because it's just not up to the
standard it's not up to the standards
and there's a lot of stuff like that
yeah right like uh if you buy like a
rolex or if you buy um like fiji water
or whatever like there's the reason why
certain things cost more or why they're
more premium there's an extreme
filtering process and it takes this many
more steps to get there when i was doing
research on his school i was reading the
background and everything and i'm like
okay cool to like for a teacher to be
hired at this school they're probably
cream of the crop in the way of the the
ethos of this school the ethos of the
school isn't super academic like they're
not looking for asian tiger mom style
teachers where they're like oh this guy
should be working at kumon they're
looking for like the most nurturing
and more uh child observant in child
uh potential
developing traits
and so i'm like okay cool
i'll have faith in this and tell
otherwise if taika comes home tells me a
story that sounds like completely
different than what the school's been
pitching i'm gonna change schools but i
because i did so much research i had so
much faith
yeah and i'm also speaking from my own
personal experience of going to [ __ ]
public school and seeing
my own teachers being [ __ ] to the
worst students in that class like i saw
one of my teachers i think in like
third or fourth grade
and this little kid was an [ __ ] but
still um like pull her [ __ ] ponytail
and this was already in the era where
you're not supposed to spank a teacher
uh pull the kid's ear and drag him out
of class [ __ ] like that you know what i
mean and i'm like shout out to antonio
is that the teacher or the student
the student it was a literally last day
of school
and then he dropped his pants and then
mooned the teacher
oh come on that you don't need to do
that the teacher um
that kid was trouble like that more than
you oh yeah
like he he was way crazier than me
and he was in on the spectrum he was
cool i don't know what the spectrum was
back then i see maybe because he would i
don't know what what you call this
that's what i'm talking about right like
teachers that just [ __ ] can't control
their own [ __ ] yeah but that's public
school too
i know but like i'm saying so that was
my initial feeling because i'm just
speaking from my own personal experience
and then going ugh
all people suck because i'm like in the
worst sad things oh i think it's
probably because
i'm a school connoisseur
so i've been to multiple schools
i've been to
public schools i've been to cream of the
crop public schools i've been to private
schools i've also seen so i've also been
in drumline and i've been in drumline of
one of the best in southern california
and then i've also been in the drumline
of one of the worst in california and i
can see like
depending on on what caliber you are
the instructor level too caliber of what
of skill money of that thing
so for example like uh
um
like so you're saying his school's
higher caliber therefore yeah like i
certainly high school right i played
drumline there
we had a band director
under the band director in the
percussion department you have your lead
drum instructor you have the snare
technician and then you have the techno
technician all four of these are faculty
the techner
technician
like the snare tech like they focus on
just that section of the drama there's
four adult faculty for just percussion
right you go to uh when i went to make
mark keppel and i walked on to to try
out for the drumline it was one band
director
and then just him
for the whole [ __ ] band
so this guy has to be like like when he
went to cerritos you have a brass
technician you have a guy that's like so
not only have a band director you have
another faculty member that focuses on
two bus trombones trumpet and you have
another guy that's a woodwind technician
who focused on clarinet uh piccolo
flutes like there's it's like you sound
like a [ __ ] geek dude nah this is
like the nba you got offensive the fact
that you said piccolo you sound [ __ ]
dweeby
what's your fault because you're with me
and so they have so they have and i know
exactly what a piccolo is because i
played flute
this is a smaller
yeah the sexier [ __ ] play pickles
yeah and then so and the non-sexier ones
play [ __ ] clarinet and [ __ ] yeah no
one likes them yeah those ones smell so
they uh well because they're sucking on
that [ __ ] reed yeah like
i'll try to talk to you the question is
saxophone uh brass or is it woodwind
would win
not that dumb
well i didn't know that but the way you
[ __ ] prepared the question it was
like oh obviously he wants him to say
that his brass because it looks like
he's brass
what about uh
your mom your mom's a [ __ ] sex what
about a bassoon because everyone gets to
blow on her what bassoon
what's the bassoon yeah the [ __ ] word
i don't know pronouncing right but
anyways so
at that level i'm like oh [ __ ] high
schools can happen yeah yeah it makes
sense and then when you go to another
one but they don't get there right it's
as the team gets better yeah we realize
we need more faculty i know but i'm just
[ __ ] irrational bro i just wanted you
to admit that you know i just wanted you
to it's called having a goddamn heart
something you wouldn't understand you
[ __ ]
i compute that everything is okay
because i've been going to multiple
schools i went to the cream of the crop
of the public school i went to the cream
of the crop of the [ __ ] band when you
have a heart you make decisions bro i
[ __ ] got with you you're absolutely
right
no that was the one time you're logical
yeah right no way i [ __ ] up you didn't
get with me i got you i [ __ ] how'd
you get me i [ __ ] threw the fishing
line in the ocean you bit it like a
little chunk yeah right
your mama's a chump
[ __ ]
you can't out your mama joke me bro by
calling her a [ __ ] i have nothing after
that exactly i love your mom by the way
shut up shut your ass up
um no but i'm just a [ __ ] unemotional
wreck it's good and bad you know what i
mean what's the good parts please please
update me
the fact that you act like a [ __ ]
little baby because i'm so nurturing i'm
a computer yeah i don't have i don't act
like a baby i just i'm very i think
you're particular i'm zeros i'm zero's
talking you start talking like no
i'm zeros and ones i'm very very
i'm like i'm like the asian lex friedman
you wish you just like beep beep just
like this
no there's only one there's only one of
them or down or left or right that's
that's the only way you want to do it
yeah okay so then um that was the first
time i'm gonna be
the next time is gonna be
probably when he gets a girlfriend
i think i'm gonna hate her
you're gonna hate her probably why i'd
be like you little [ __ ]
why are you going to hate her because my
son sees herself in her
you see herself in her that's why no
because it's my boy he's [ __ ] perfect
and this stupid hussy is going to come
and corrupt my poor little baby
because you see yourself in the hussy no
i'm a [ __ ] queen bro every guy that i
chose to be with yeah was super elevated
once they were with me
well after we broke up i don't know what
happened to them they definitely didn't
succeed yeah um but like look at you
what about me
you got with me your life is elevated no
i elevated your scummy ass life
why you gotta be so mean dude
because i'm zeros on ones that's it fine
um why why no i don't honestly honestly
yeah honestly i'm gonna hate her really
why
no i won't but it's gonna break my heart
because now i know he's like like he's
that's it like
i'm not the only woman in his life you
know what i mean like right now i'm like
his favorite woman what about the first
time you find jizz stains in his
underwear it's gonna be funny oh really
yeah it's gonna be funny and i'm gonna
be like oh damn it like that's it the
little boy is gone gone then wouldn't
you be happy that he has a girlfriend
because now he could do the real real
with no
what what do you mean what you [ __ ]
robot would you rather have him [ __ ]
dry humping all the couches 100
hump all the [ __ ] furniture bro
please what if it turns into like a
catholic priest
why the [ __ ] would he turn into a
catholic cree who's catholic here you
are not really
you see a house not by choice those guys
are so [ __ ] riled up because they're
just dry humping their robes all day
that has nothing to do with the [ __ ]
catholic church those are just some
[ __ ] perverted ass people that are
getting [ __ ]
covered by other perverted ass people
with a lot of [ __ ] money so [ __ ]
those people it has nothing to do with
the catholic [ __ ] church
yeah but i just don't know religion at
least i just want him to get too riled
up the business that i don't want
[ __ ] it up i don't want him to get
too riled up because sex make you do
crazy [ __ ] you didn't have any sex for
[ __ ] many years you were you're fine
kind of i had a warm liquid pocket [ __ ]
yeah why can't he have a warm liquid
pocket [ __ ]
you had no game to get no real so you
would buy him a warm liquid pocket i'm
not buying him [ __ ] he's getting his own
i don't know on amazon i'm going to
teach him how to hustle for money
so he's going to make his own money and
when he makes his own money he can spend
it however he wants to i'm not buying
him [ __ ] that's fine
uh to be honest i think um
sometimes i think back
and instead of like [ __ ] my little
pocket [ __ ]
you wish you had game
i did have game you didn't have any game
i had sick game
but i was so i had such um religious
guilt
that for some reason it felt
more right to [ __ ] my pocket [ __ ] than
to do it with chicks isn't that weird
uh
well what was your religion like
i didn't grow up with much sex you know
with much like sex talk we know that you
[ __ ] geek like sex talk or like
emotions or anything like that or
relationships
um
so even though i lost where's the
religion part of it though like how
muslim buddhism you don't indulge in any
of like the primal
[Music]
urges besides sex what are the other
ones all of them like when you're hungry
you better [ __ ] fast
that's funny because you indulge in that
all the goddamn exactly i've got no
[ __ ] faith yeah every you need to
what's the other one um
attachment to materialistic things look
at you you better give that [ __ ] away
you're not that bad with that one yeah
you better give that [ __ ] away yeah you
don't give a [ __ ] about that so i'll get
i'll i'll say you got here so these two
you suck this one's you're good it was
the other one um
emotions
emotions that you better not get riled
up by people okay you're actually pretty
good with that one too yeah like if
someone can like move you uh you're kind
of in the middle if someone could like
emotionally rile you up then you're
you're not yeah you're kind of in the
mood you're not you're not that means
you're too indulgent in your emotions
always another one
that's the main one like you just want
to indulge in your primal feelings so
emotions
hunger
[ __ ]
um like a materialistic thing like
hoarding like gluttony like all those
things you don't you don't want to uh
you want to be in control of yourself
you don't want something to pull you
into their world yeah but they're so
good i know
but
um i can't help that i've been a high
test
child
so i was just [ __ ] horny oh
testosterone yeah i was a [ __ ] high
test child so i was [ __ ] horny and
then because i had the religious guilt
um i did lose my virginity
pretty early well not even that early
15. that's [ __ ] early i got homies i
lost virginia with like 12. yeah but
when you're in the [ __ ] hood that's
you don't go by that standard okay dude
okay so last time's 15
and that's [ __ ] young and then uh
you weren't even legal you couldn't even
drive your own car you're not even
allowed to vote you can't even drink
you're a [ __ ] baby did you even have
any pubes
i was 15
yeah
are you sure i mean that was probably
uneven
probably mr burns probably just like
couple here a couple there side yeah yes
i don't know so i had um yeah i i uh i
lost it early
and then i had a lot of chances
and then i had a lot of girls that liked
me uh after you lost it yeah but i
turned a lot of them down
um okay don't be exaggerated bro what's
like a lot
you know you know a lot of them no i
only know [ __ ] two well that's
because that's when we're together but
like yeah so that's not a lot
oh well i don't know there's there's
girls that like me
and i just felt so
guilty too like like i think like at
that point because you just you had to
fight the urge of giving it to them so
good yeah
i think at that age is the age if if you
knew someone liked you
uh then you knew you could have sex
right even though if you don't feel the
other way and i think a lot of that's
different for guys and girls and a lot
of dudes would have done it
um like the random [ __ ] at a party or
whatever but i just felt so guilty you
had friends that would get random
[ __ ] at a party yeah
what like i i i just didn't um
i i didn't feel right you know i just
felt like i have to be in a committed
relationship i have to love you remember
that one time we were in uh austin and
we were at this club and it was at two
level clubs oh yeah and there was this
drunk chick that wanted to use the
bathroom she kept trying to shake the
door open but it was locked yeah but
then there's a sign that says like
maintenance room yeah and she's like
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] taking forever and
uh we were just like looking at her and
then this random dude comes and he
starts talking to her and then so we
ignore them because we're like okay
they're like flirting so we ignore them
and then we look at them like maybe 10
minutes later and
she's like up against the wall he's
facing the wall and she's just sucking
his dick
out in the open that was wild i'd never
seen that before i love texas
because of that one thing it's a good
place
that's a good lady yeah but yeah i had i
had like religious guilt so like um i
think it just felt that enough though
you're losing it at 15. it felt more
holy to to [ __ ] a piece of plastic i
think really you didn't feel guilty
[ __ ] plastic i did too that i did too
yeah like she was just masturbating you
felt [ __ ] up yeah that's a bummer but
you can't stop it you know
yeah yeah my mind's telling me no
but my body
my body's telling me bust yeah you can't
help it
i know that feeling
what's even worse is just guilty 100
what'd you do about it
i just went under the cover so i
couldn't see all the [ __ ] all the
jesus [ __ ] pictures my mom had
everywhere and the rosaries and the
[ __ ] virgin guadalupe and the [ __ ]
sun huda staring at me every time you
needed a bus you're like hey mom i'm
going to take a nap no it was when no
one's home oh
and then if i'm doing it in the bathroom
yeah then um
nothing's in there you can't put no
jesus pieces in there yeah
it was [ __ ] how many times you jack off
when
during the during your prime as [ __ ]
often as i could so like five times a
day no i i i wasn't an only child you
loser oh how many times a day
if it was probably how many times a week
it wasn't like a daily occurrence
amateur
no i had a house full of people i lived
with five other people
maybe six if my grandma is visiting from
mexico and she lived with us for like
months at a time my palm count was like
in the thousands
why do you have that face i'm a player
like that i know i remember you telling
me you jacked off a lot even when we
were together you said you jacked off a
lot
what's up with that i can't help it i
got [ __ ] high tea
so it was just like how many times a day
were you jacking off i know i think i
tested my limits and i think like
i think after like it looks like you're
gonna say five
yeah like i think i did five but i
realized anything after three kind of
hurts
but you still had to do two more
yeah what is it is it because you're
just like [ __ ] i feel it again yeah but
then your dick can't handle it you know
like the sex urge is there but then your
dick can't handle it no i don't know
that what is that like it's like mind
over matter
what do you mean your dick can't have
because it's raw it's
it's like too sensitive
you know what
how about like how back to back are you
doing it because like
no no you don't you know brother you
know you know you know when you're
gobbling on my dick
you know when you're gobbling on it and
then you win that sweet nectar comes out
no
and then you continue to keep gobbling
and i'm like oh oh oh
yeah yeah yeah i like talking with you
yep yeah that um
that feeling it takes i don't know it
takes a while to go away what's a while
i don't know maybe like 30 minutes an
hour or whatever and then later so you
had to do it you i wouldn't know that no
i wouldn't do it back to back but then
later
um like later on you still have a little
bit lingering and when you do it again
it has a little bit lean green a little
bit more than it's more and more and
more yeah so by the time like you're
doing it i don't know like the fifth
time um
what's coming out at the fifth time
dude sometimes it's just [ __ ] like
arrowhead water
it's just like clear
yeah you're all out of nuts and what's
what do your nuts look like at that
point
does that even change they just look
like empty pouches i think like like
when you get your dog [ __ ] spayed or
neutered which one is it i mean you
can't tell but that's what it feels like
yeah have you seen the dog's [ __ ]
ball sack yeah
yeah it just flaps
it's sad it's really sad
why don't they just take that whole
thing off like why keep the sack on it
it feels like
it feels like we're mocking them you
know what i mean like haha we took out
your balls but you can stare where they
used to be you know i like that they
leave it there why
because you could pull on it
why would you want to pull on it this is
cute that's [ __ ] up i don't pull on
hard there's no reason for you to even
pull on it i like putting my dog
everywhere i wish they were i wish they
were a furry though they are very small
not what
yeah meatloaf was kind of furry
maybe an insurance he has more he has
more peach fuzz i mean it's not the same
there's some there's some dogs that just
have straight up [ __ ] man balls oh oh
yeah that's weird you know those gsp
dogs yeah yeah yeah yeah they're all
furry and cute and [ __ ] and then they
open up and there's literally like the
most perfect oh yeah polished balls yeah
yeah yeah it's so weird i'm like what
the [ __ ] even cats have it too
they got their little almond sized
little nuts some reason i look at all
cats and i think they're all females
isn't that weird not weird i think
because they're just so pretty you
[ __ ] pervert
what yeah cause you think they're all
girls and i just think they're
i think it's because they all look very
feminine oh because they're just their
eyes that have like yeah yeah the
eyeliner
yeah yeah yeah and they have these
beautiful like lashes and [ __ ] they're
just gorgeous creatures yeah
yeah but i uh
yeah i busted and busted nuts and then
it would be really sensitive did you
ever get caught busting
i think you said your mom
couple times one time was by my roommate
but she didn't know
and that was really like my ears oh we
know dude my my ears turn how do you
think she doesn't know and i'll tell you
if she knew
oh i'm [ __ ] slick
let me know and then i'll tell you so um
i know my room everyone knows each
other's schedules right when you're
roommates with people in college
so i was like okay cool everyone's
leaving whatever and then i had like um
i don't know maybe like two hours or
something like that so i got ready
did the little stretch you know about to
get crazy up in here and then i pull my
pants down to my ankles where are you at
where you at you know my oh so you know
my college apartment you know how like
my my mattress my pa my mattress is on
this side of the room okay and then
there's a coffee table no i don't
remember oh so there was a table i think
i only went there like less than five
times okay so there's a table a couch
coffee table tv my bed's right here i
put the laptop on um the coffee table oh
[ __ ] you were just out in the open like
disgusting well i know they're not
supposed to be home disgusting so i
pulled it i started playing with myself
and all of a sudden i hear the uh the
door
oh [ __ ] so i just pulled did you have
audio was it was it
loud i don't remember but i'm i i hope
not i pulled i pulled it up real quick
and then i was like oh hey how's it
going and then uh for sure she knew you
were jacking off how would she know
because there's a lot of movement she
didn't hear it she's on the other side
of the door she's probably thinking her
own [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i left this thing right
she's in a state of panic
like why is she back at that time she's
never there at the time
yeah so it was like this close and i
just remember like my ears turning like
you know when you're about to get caught
regardless if you know if they know
it's just like a oh
like that so i'm like oh [ __ ] and i was
like oh look at him look at pretend i'm
like looking around just moving
and then like making my bed or whatever
and then i was like oh [ __ ] almost got
caught my [ __ ] dick out that'd be
weird that would have been so awkward
dude because you live with this chick
yeah
and then she would have been like ew
i don't want to live with this [ __ ]
sex addict
or it would have been normal because you
know college dorm behavior yeah but
she's asian like that's not it's not but
it's still college yeah but it's still
asian like there's with age like if i
lived with my community of people i'm
like that's not what it might be
dude [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i knew that was coming then
why'd you set yourself up for that
because i thought you were gonna take
the high road but i should have known
better you're [ __ ] scum and you're
trash
and you don't you don't deserve me or or
to be like introduced to my [ __ ]
beautiful culture
is that what you call it
oh don't act like you don't like it my
culture is [ __ ] bubbling
yes
you love the women the food
the traditions those the [ __ ] unity
those women
and you and none of them want anything
to do with you nah i got i got they love
me
they go ha ha
[Laughter]
they hand me my number i mean their
number all the time
yeah
five five five never mind
wait what are we talking oh that you
almost got i never got
not even close to cot imagine they all
everyone already knew
like i wasn't that discreet i mean you
didn't do it that much
oh yeah that's true you'll need a couple
times a week yeah i mean i just there
was five other people in there amateur
numbers that's okay that's okay
i'd rather live the life
safely and
yeah that would have [ __ ] been
mortifying dude i remember the time my
brother so um
we only had
so at this point we had moved to a
slightly bigger house and now we had two
bathrooms which was really rad um there
was a bathroom in my parents mask the
master bedroom
and then there was one for the rest of
us
um and there was four of us and then my
parents so there's six people total
and if um someone was taking a shower
you you had to leave the door unlocked
because someone might have to use the
toilet right the pooper yeah so i
remember i had just started my period it
was first year i had a period or
whatever and like um i don't know why i
didn't throw my [ __ ] pad away in the
in the
in the uh trash maybe we didn't have it
or whatever but it's like you know those
thick [ __ ] pads yeah um i took my
clothes off and i just took my underwear
and i placed the pad like on like flat
on the floor just because i i don't know
why i didn't roll it up maybe i didn't
even know that you could roll it out all
the blood was just showing yeah so
you're just showing
well no one's supposed to come in
you're supposed to knock too right
um so i just left it there and then my
brother just busts in and he's he's like
sitting down maybe he's gonna poop or
something and then i just him go what
the
what the [ __ ]
i'm like what the hell's wrong
what the [ __ ] and he's like cussing and
stuff and i'm like why he's like you're
[ __ ] nasty you're so [ __ ] gross
[Laughter]
and i'm like what's happening he's like
you [ __ ] dirty [ __ ] likewise it's
just you left your [ __ ] bloody pad
and i was like oh [ __ ] my bad dude
i probably didn't say my bad but i was
like [ __ ] you you ever get skid marks on
your pad
skid marks on your pad it doesn't go
that far back oh it doesn't and it
doesn't go in between your ass crack it
shouldn't i don't know how far because
the pad is like those thick ones yeah
yeah yeah um there's panty liners which
are way thinner and i guess it's just
meant for like super light days or for
just women that like pee a little bit
can you pee on it
you can but i think you're gonna would
it like absorb it all like not all
because it just depends on the amount of
piss you have right
um
so it would definitely overflow but yeah
you can pee on it
oh damn
yeah that's cool it's like a diaper
almost not really it's not going to hold
that much it's probably going to hold
like one second worth of piss oh yeah
it's not that much i see
yeah you want to try it
i'll beat it
beat what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] maxi
pad what do you mean beat it how you're
seeing if it could contain my piss yeah
i'll piss any day
no i'm just thinking if you just want to
try it of course it's going to overflow
of course
there's no way what is there to try
see what it feels like
it feels like what me peeing on it yeah
the word pad and just kind of pee a
little bit i've done that before why
because you're only child you're [ __ ]
bored okay what did you do
i um i it's like one of those days i'm
just like which is probably every day
i'm just bored so i'm just digging
around the house opening up all the
cabinets and i saw my mom's pads and
then i would just always think of like
you know did it all ma'am did all moms
[ __ ] have [ __ ] thick pads does
your mom have them that's all they had
back then
all right and then so i would see like
you know those commercials they put that
blue liquid on whatever and then i'm
like
let me let me try it so like i i taped
and i was like oh cool there's like
there's tape i'm oh this is good
technology so i put it on my underwear
and i'd put it on how did you know to
put it oh cause you saw your mom do that
yeah and i'd pee and it would start
coming out and i was like oh [ __ ] you
can't handle my piss
but i don't know if girls peed less or
whatever so you thought it was only to
catch p no no i knew it was for like
whatever girl [ __ ] it was but i just
wanted to see if it could hold uh piss
yeah did your mom ever talk to you about
what it is and why you why she pieced i
mean why she bleeds
um she just told me it happens uh like
once a month and she's gonna turn into a
[ __ ]
she did not say that no she just she
just says that girls have to have this
thing and it's blood
yeah but she didn't say it's like my
eggs it comes from my ovaries yeah yeah
yeah and not none of that are you like
how does it hurt
i think it was so part of my life
it um
i never questioned it you know it's just
like oh i've always seen my mom change
her pad and stuff like that and i've
seen my grandma change and she didn't
look like she's like an agonizing pain
so you're like oh it must be fine yeah
because my grandma would have like an
old school chinese pad what the [ __ ] is
that like a [ __ ] reusable fabric
and what should she tie it like a
underwear does she put it in yeah yeah
yeah yeah what to which one so my
grandma's underwear it would be [ __ ]
trippy because it had buttons and [ __ ]
you ever seen underwear with buttons
well where are the buttons it's like it
comes over and there's like four buttons
okay this is when they used to make
things that need to last forever so it's
not all soft and [ __ ] cute it was
[ __ ] like canvas and it was like this
uh like
i don't know it looked like almost like
a um
like the same belt that someone i worked
at home depot would have where you would
like put like pencils and rulers like
that material that's how thick it looked
and so she would have this and then the
buttons would come over and then you
could like tie it on the side and had
like an extra layer and then so you i
would see her like separate it and then
like scrub it almost like the mask that
we wear like you would scrub it and then
you would have stains from like the last
couple of times it's really hard to get
blood out and she would hang hang it all
and then when she had her period and she
would take that attach it to that
underwear put that underwear on
crazy yeah imagine if doctor strange
made
women's underwear like it looked like
that it was like [ __ ] layers and [ __ ]
how uncomfortable look at the [ __ ] we go
through yeah and you can't be nice to me
what do you mean you don't deserve it i
i just created the perfect human for you
and i don't deserve a little bit of
kindness i think i created him didn't i
oh i didn't see him come out of your
[ __ ] [ __ ] or dick hole well you're
just a toaster i'm the actual yeah who
do you think gave him the nutrients
what do you mean i give him the
nutrients where
i [ __ ] he was a leech to my body for
nine months what are you talking about
good
take it
yeah so be nice to me you [ __ ] troll
bag i am nice to you i love you so much
you're my favorite i better be am i your
favorite mexican girl
one of them
because my mom the second or the first
one or the second one nah she's just
she's the one that's living on the list
that i love
ah
all right before we get in a [ __ ]
fight because we always fight on this
podcast do we we never fight yeah um is
there anything else you want to add why
are your pants what's going on with your
pants over there where
anyway anything else you want to add no
all right i hate you too fine you're
gonna be nice to me okay good
um that's it that's all we got thank you
for listening
see you guys next time bye